Let's go next to our caller from the six three
zero area code.
Who's calling today from six three zero
is that me?
Yes it is.
Hey Dave, this is Ruben and I want to congratulate
you on almost crossing 800,000 subscribers.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
So I have a question when it comes to hip
hop.
Okay.
So out of the three hip hop artists, uh, who
would you choose personally?
Tupac or notorious big, known as biggie or
easy?
Uh, I would go with Tupac myself.
I mean, it's, uh, it's, it's pretty cut and
dry.
Yeah.
I w I, I absolutely agree.
Even though I like them all and the majority
of the new hip hop artists who I would choose
to pop out of all out of all the hip hop artists,
I'm less familiar with easy ease material
and I don't want to make it seem like, I think
Tupac is orders of magnitude greater than
a notorious pig.
But I do think that for me the decision is
clear.
Yeah.
I've, I've listened to easy, but I, and his
songs are pretty amazing, but I think vog
is way better than easy.
All right, well you've, you've drawn a line
in the sand and we will see how the audience
reacts.
All right, sure.
No problem.
Thank you for the call and a happy new year.
Okay, thanks.
Hi.
Happy new year as well.
Thank you so much